well along the lines of that scenario
we've got some interesting information
liz bates our political correspondence
is here with me because uh sky sources
uh are hearing uh
about the prime minister's mood about
the prime minister's well decision tell
us yes so we've had the latest on this
after everything that's happened today
we've seen cabinet ministers going in
and out of this building
urging him to sundown what we understand
is that the prime minister remains
defiant he is not going to stand down he
is going to continue imposed and try to
keep this government going and
if you think that is quite incredible to
be in that scenario where the prime
minister of the day is having to
confirm he is going to stay in office
and that's purely because of all of the
things that we've seen building up today
we just saw him in prime minister's
questions that was a really difficult
moment for him lots of mps sitting
really glumly on the back bench as well
things have hugely deteriorated since
then and we have the situation cabinet
ministers going in urging him to stand
down some of those cabinet ministers
some of the most supportive and loyal uh
people around him including people like
pretty patel also we understand that she
has decided
she has switched sides and said to him
with a heavy heart that it's time for
him to go that he can no longer carry on
even the the chairman of the 1922
committee sir
brady is understood to be uh preparing
to advise him that he cannot continue
and should think about his future and at
the same time as that's been happening
over here we've had mps across in
parliament uh try discussing whether
they can change the rules to force
another vote of no confidence and so
he's been pushed and pushed it does feel
like the walls are closing in even down
at the gates here
we can see there's a wall of people it
feels like things are really closing in
on the prime minister and yet he is
saying uh this evening he remains
defiant he will carry on he still has a
few supporters we just saw jacob
rees-mogg coming out earlier we know
nadine doris the culture secretary
a very loyal supporter of his still on
his side but they are really dwindling
at this point